الكولونيل كيف تنتهز أوكرانيا هذه
الفوضى الآن
بشكل جيد ، هناك العديد من الأشياء التي يمكنهم
فعلها أليسون وكما ذكر ديفيد ، هناك
الكثير من الأشياء التي يمكن للأوكرانيين أن
ينظروا إليها هنا في الواقع ، أحد الأشياء التي
أعتقد أنهم سيفعلونها هو ربما
ملاحقة مصلحتهم
تفوقهم التكتيكي في باهوت على سبيل المثال
سيكون محاميًا رئيسيًا نقطة
محتملة للأوكرانيين
شيء آخر يمكنهم فعله هو
انسحاب القوات الروسية المحتمل للدفاع
ضد مجموعة فاغنر أه
يمكنهم ردم تلك المنطقة والاستيلاء على
المناطق التي يسيطر عليها الروس  تم التخلي عنها إذا
حدث ذلك ، لا نعرف ما إذا كان هذا
سيحدث ولكن هذه هي
الأشياء التي سيبحث
عنها الأوكرانيون ، أنا متأكد من أنهم
سيستفيدون منها على الأرجح
بأسرع ما يمكن أن يكونوا
أجانب